welcome are you ready to fight some
beasts in beast man be smash the same
okay I have no idea what this game is I
assume it's sort of like the other one
we played remember that one of course
you do you watch all my videos goddamn
right you do all right where should we
go
soccer let's save these for later okay
let's start with good old grasslands
okay all right so what did we go this is
it okay this is the grasslands very
exciting not so exciting okay we can
spawn we can spoil and all kinds of [ __ ]
oh my god let's start with seagull okay
we got a sick how about two seagulls
there you go versus of course a tank who
would win
[Laughter]
that the tag wins everybody surprised
surprised everybody the tag what if we
add a zebra to the mix huh uh without a
fix things come on deep breath oh I'm
gonna look away from that okay the tank
the tank wins
how about we're gonna add a t-rex we're
gonna add a weight what the [ __ ] is this
okay okay this is interesting this is
interesting
come on come on you son of a [ __ ] fight
him like a man oh [ __ ]
tank misses he doesn't really know how
to attack it he's like oh [ __ ] his his
leg got blown off its leg got blown up
and then they need the tank is strong
humans are strong come on Dino you gotta
win this one what about a raptor huh
what about couple Raptors come on
Raptors
come on wrestlers eat that take all the
rest of it mold they get mold I say okay
well clearly clearly this is not gonna
work we're gonna need when a t-rex right
the t-rex a bunch of tear a bunch of
freakin t-rex here we go come on t-rex
get that tank make tank its strong man
gasps good job Dino good job
you work together as a team and you can
do anything
this is amazing this game is incredible
all right let's keep it back at as
simple a kangaroo right versus seagull
I felt like seagulls they're pretty good
whoa jumped over seagull OH
who won I can't even tell they're still
fighting I believe seagull won
no no seagull loss okay how many
seagulls does it take to one kill one
kangaroo oh my lord
well good job seagull wins
how many seagulls does it take to kill
one t-rex oh my god they're strong yeah
go forth mix oh my god it's spitting out
go seagulls get up get him seek oh god
I'll take us da dinkles
how are you can fight fight god dammit
seagulls sing up come on there's two
left come out seagulls
it's plus its goes sing us the seagulls
are strong goddammit
holy [ __ ] seagulls mein what about
seagulls versus a minigun huh seagulls
are freakin amazing
what about against a barrel huh that's
the point how about a Spinosaurus what
that hell oh okay who knew seagulls
seagulls were the greatest animal alive
oh I've never been more proud of you see
ghosts I'm not sure how they are
fighting to be honest look at it
the ruthless animals ruthless wait they
actually play football okay dog right
team dog vs. team elephant what would
win a bunch of dogs vs. an elephant come
on little dolly sausage dogs as well oh
okay well
oh no oh no oh oh wow okay all right
well that that answer that question okay
all right well okay okay all right all
right all right let's clear up the dogs
Cosette was horrible what about my
famous seagull huh
what about my favorite favorite famous
seagulls there we go okay come on both
seagulls are strong come on sing please
just throw themselves after the ball
come out seagulls play us a team play us
a team
hey go hey go Jake good hey go look at
him go
all right what a bunch a bunch of
raptors they're pretty fast right come
on come on Chico damn they're killing it
they can take your coat
they can take control wrap it stand no
chance say goes the strongest animal
alive guys damn a Pokemon we're real you
know I will picked seagulls you know it
what about the bridge Triceratops huh
what a bunch of bunch look I'm in it's
okay I'm gonna give you so many goddamn
Triceratops there's no way you can lose
this Triceratops your stupid animal as
well I hated you in that cartoon with
the annoying girl character oh my lord
come on sickles there's not many of you
left come on seagulls you missed say go
we're gonna try that again we're gonna
try that again
come on seagulls come on seagulls use
your teamwork tactic Hill Oh No
oh oh I don't know what just happened
but I don't think it was pretty there's
still one brave seagull fighting off
he's fighting against five fresh Saratov
come on seagull oh wow oh oh oh this is
the greatest game of all time the
Colosseum yes the ancient Romans used to
battle
oh but pterodactyls Jess Go Go yeah Oh
gasps my bar get that tank oh he lost
his leg that's fine he didn't need legs
he's a bird oh my god yes did it win
they won
oh my garlic Patera doctor has to be my
favorite animal my favorite dinosaur
this got really interesting because how
many prepared actives
will they take to kill a seagull right
surely these seagulls you had no chance
oh my god oh my god he got missed
you got messed up right away seagulls
don't mess around
Chico so much I bet you three seagulls
can kill this
one day
come up
look ah no no Peter Oh Peter I'm so
disappointed
finally we get the scientific answers of
all these questions that we've asked
ourselves for a very very very long time
at least I have I don't know I think
about these things okay so we I didn't
know you could put stuff on people so
Seigle right siegel right here laser you
can't you can't put a laser on them how
about a bomb okay all right how about
this
put it on the other side huh Rhino with
guns
lates are freaking seagulls can they all
have lasers okay okay okay this is gonna
be awesome it's gonna be awesome it's
gonna be awesome it's gonna be awesome
okay so Frank t-rex right t-rex all
right three frickin t-rex and then to
make it more fair we give them one dog
[Music]
Oh dog I got bad
you're really brain
Oh No
[Music]
man
well
[Music]
that is up
well this has been beast battle
simulator thank you for leaving a like
on this video fame squad jujitsu